[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carson palmer back with us all right
fourth and three
you got mac jones playing well
you got 37-yard line you got a defensive
secondary that's depleted
why didn't bill belichick go for it with
mack jones
well i just think belichick's used to
having great kickers and he has a ton of
confidence in his kicker you go back
from
steven guskowski you go back to vina
terry
he had a lot of confidence i know it's
rainy there was no wind
but that was a game winner and and he
went for it just simply because he's got
a lot of confidence in a special team's
crew yeah but i'm gonna give brady the
ball
even though he's down with 55 seconds to
go in two timeouts
i don't want brady having the ball where
he can go down you know he's got to go
35 maybe 40 yards
to win the game
yeah but the way that that game was
going defensively he was frustrating
brady all game long defensively they
were they were bringing a lot of
different pressures giving them a lot of
different looks i just felt you know
watching that and seeing that decision
unfold he felt like he was going to kick
the game winner and then kick the ball
off and stop brady on defense which
would have been a pretty belichicki
thing to do
if brady is belichick's quarterback last
night
is he going forward on fourth and three
i don't think so i i think when you when
you watch belichick and you just the
history of what he's done
he sticks by his guns he does what he
does he confuses he confuses the
opposing quarterback he brings a lot of
different pressures he plays great
defense he wins games with special teams
and unfortunately it didn't happen last
night with the special teams kick at the
end that they missed okay what is it
like going against belichick
really frustrating you know i
unfortunately two different times in my
career had to open up in a season opener
against him which typically when you
play against belichick you love to have
three four five six seven game weeks of
film to watch preparing unfortunately
two different times i'm a mo for two and
an opener against belichick just because
you don't know what to watch you know
you can watch all the preseason film you
want there's nothing you can really pick
up from that you can watch the prior
seasons film and the playoff games that
he most likely played in the year before
and get somewhat of a feel for what he
does defensively but in openers he's
really really difficult and for brady
obviously it was really difficult last
night it was a frustrating game for
brady obviously there's a lot of hoopla
around the return but he he frustrated
brady he brought a lot of different
pressures and he showed a ton of
different looks and played a bunch of
different coverages and brady never
really as you watched the game go on
never really felt very comfortable and
confident what he was seeing pre-snap
and then post-snap how is it possible
brady's going to see something he's
never seen before in
playing over 20 years at that position
i i don't think there is anything he's
never seen before but consistently he
never saw the same coverage he saw a lot
of different looks pre-snap and then a
lot of different looks that turned out
to be different coverages post snap so
it wasn't anything new or some new
defense that belichick made up he just
consistently kept him unnerved he
brought a lot of different five-man
pressures i mean you you looked at
what tampa does and tampa likes to
spread you out and getting five-man
protections and have five receivers run
the routes and
belichick
consistently gave him looks where there
was possibly six guys coming
but they never really made brady throw
hot very often they consistently brought
five-man pressures which got defensive
linemen in one-on-one situations with
their offensive lineman you know that
that's what's frustrated brady
throughout his career you go back to the
super bowl losses uh against the new
york giants and and um the games that
brady really struggled with were
pressures and and defensive blitzes and
that's what you saw all night long in
new england last night
you on the cardinals bandwagon
i'm on it i'm on it i'm uh we're 4-0
right now i think we have the most
exciting team in the nfl to watch i
think we have them
yeah oh i'm allowed to say we 100 i've
earned that right so wait are you saying
the bengals are we are the raiders a wee
for you just the cardinals are we
i'm a cardinal uh that's why i finished
my career that's what my kids those are
the jerseys my kids wear on sunday so
i'm a cardinal fan okay all right so
what makes you uh any issues with the
cardinals
um
you know i would say offensive line
could be an issue but but kyler murray
is that dynamic where he doesn't need
five pro bowlers blocking for him i
think right now he's the mvp of the
league if he can keep up what he's doing
i think he's the most valuable player in
the league defensively we can stop the
run
you got chandler jones you got isaiah
you got a not a lot of speed pass
rushers you got some power pass rushers
so i just like the complete package that
we the cardinals have right now we're
talking to carson palmer former nfl
quarterback uh ben roethlisberger it
didn't look pretty
how much of this is on ben though carson
and how much of this is
directed redirected to the offensive
line or play calling or whatever it
might be
it's all of it i mean it's all of it
they're they're not the offensive line
they were four or five years ago when
they had villanueva and just the pro
bowlers they had stacked up up front in
the first round picks they had stepped
up stacked up so you know part of it's
that but a lot of it too has been you
know it's it's it's not easy to watch
right now you're seeing a quarterback
that can't quite
create the same velocity with with each
throw some throws are beautiful you saw
the over-the-shoulder go throw he threw
it that was a nice long completion but
you know consistently you saw it at the
end of you know i felt it at the end of
my career you saw at the end of peyton's
career you saw it at the end of drew
brees's career
balls are starting to really kind of
fade off at the end and die
there's not a ton of velocity and a lot
of zip on the throws so as this season
goes on and again i mean it's we're
going into 17 games now ben's used to
play in 16 games or
13 14 15 games with with some of the
injuries he's had over the last handful
of years but going 17 games without that
offensive line that he's used to having
without that massive run game that he's
had throughout his career and he doesn't
have all the weapons i mean claypool is
a nice threat on the outside but he
doesn't have the antonio browns and the
san antonio homes and the antoine
randall and heinz were all these great
players you can think back through bin's
career he's not playing with the same
weaponry he has in the past and then you
throw out that one of the best defensive
linemen best defensive players in the
nfl's got the groin injury so i mean
seeing ben you know at this point in
stage in his career and with the lack of
weapons he has on offensive defense it's
looking like a long year for the
steelers
what's the first thing to go on a
quarterback
um
you know just it just depends when you
look at ben it's it's the transfer await
into every throw
it's like i said earlier it's that
velocity he does not have that same
velocity when he needs to rip a dig in
over the middle that's a you know a ball
that needs to carry 30 to you know 20 to
30 yards when he's throwing a comeback
from the left hash to the right sideline
that that ball has to carry 30 yards in
the air you're just not seeing the ball
get there as quickly and as rapidly and
when that ball hangs in the air these
dbs are so fast and so explosive and
close cushion and closed coverage so
fast that when you start getting the 36
37 38 years old and the balls hanging in
the air that's a bad recipe
but brady still has that arm strength
right and and roger still has that arm
strength
and that's rare at because it feels like
you know you mentioned you philip rivers
drew brees peyton manning now ben
you know you have only so many throws in
those arms those shoulders and
especially if you have surgery but is
this
how much of this is core and body
strength because brady is really big on
that core with that torque to be able to
deliver the ball and as he said hey i'm
not losing anything off my fastball
oh a ton of its core and a ton of it is
lower body i mean that that's your
foundation and that is where the ball
going into a throwing motion all starts
it's from that back hip it's
transferring the weight and it
absolutely blows my mind watching brady
throw the ball at 44. i mean the ball
still has velocity on it it still has
zip there's a couple times last night
you saw him moving within the pocket
because you lose the arm and you lose
the velocity but you also lose that
bounce in your step and that explosion
when you get to the top of the drop and
you need to shift and slide into the
middle or the soft spot of the pocket
and you saw that a little bit with
peyton you're seeing it with ben you're
not seeing it with brady he still has
that pop he took off and ran for a first
down on third and seven last night and
he looked like he was 28. i just don't
get it it boggles my mind but as far as
the bounce and the pop and the pep in
his step he's got it as far as velocity
and the ball not tailing off at the end
and the ball not being affected by
different wind directions brady's not
losing that he still has that and when
he talks about playing until 50 maybe
he's right maybe he does
what is it like i i don't know if you
felt this way but
you you go out there and you you're not
excited to be out there as the starting
quarterback that you just
you're not having fun or you don't feel
well
like have you had that did you have that
feeling where this is my job
but i don't
i don't want to go out
here i i haven't felt that and and i
haven't played with many guys that have
felt that or at least i haven't played
with many guys that i sensed were
feeling that what i what i have played
with and what i have seen
is especially in running backs when you
don't quite have the juice to get you
through a hole or get you through a seam
on third and three that you used to be
able to get to and you don't quite have
that pop or that pep in your step to
explode through the line of scrimmage
i've seen that happen to guys and
it's deflating it it wrecks your
confidence
it wrecks your morale you maybe don't
quite have the same love for the game
because it's so much more difficult or
you you know that you physically can't
do what you used to be able to do so
i've definitely seen that but as far as
as guys just not wanting to play and not
loving the game anymore
you know after you get to seven eight
nine ten years in the league the only
reason you got to that point is because
you have that love and that fire will
always burn
but you know i haven't i haven't seen
that and if you have let me know with
certain guys but i've seen that
lack of explosion that lack of athletic
ability i mean you see it in running
backs kind of at that 31 32 33 years old
age where guys start losing that
explosiveness well there's
there's defensive backs who don't want
to tackle sometimes
and and there's running backs who are
just tired of getting pounded instead of
going inside they want to dance outside
i i remember watching defensive backs
you know
we've seen with running backs jerome
bettis talks about it he said i knew
there were defensive backs that just
didn't want to tackle me that it was
just they knew it was gonna hurt and uh
but but they knew they they had to give
the impression so they do the arm tackle
or go you know uh
so i i could imagine that you you'd see
somebody come through the line and
you're just going oh this is gonna hurt
oh i would uh i would always put myself
in situations like
what would happen i would just mentally
see like i used to play against jerome
bettis and i've actually stood on the
other sideline in warm-ups and watched
him and i've sat there and mentally
thought
what would i do if i was standing in the
b gap
and the bus was coming downhill and he
had two arms on the ball and i saw the
36 on his forehead get low what would i
do
would i be able to keep my eyes open and
at least try to get in his way or at
least be a speed bump in his way so i
i've definitely i i uh you know i can
understand that feeling for corners
especially when you're a corner and
you're 160 pounds or 185 pounds and you
got 240 coming at you and it runs 4-2
that's a problem
i mentioned this earlier in the show
that having that cornerback who can take
away one side of the field trayvon diggs
of the cowboys looks like he's a a true
shutdown corner what does it do to your
game plan
when you're facing and you face a lot of
great defensive backs but they're taking
away your best guy and taking like
jerrell rivas used to do this or dion
used to do that what's that like when
you go i can't go there
well it just it shrinks your game plan i
mean you you can go into a game plan and
have 150 past calls
and when you have to shut down half the
field for 150 of your play calls
especially we we had a tough time in in
cincinnati with chad and troy cinco
because darrell reavis would line up on
him
and he would give us fits i mean he was
so difficult in one-on-one press
coverage and the great thing that
darrell rivas had behind him was rex
ryan because he had that defensive front
that he could bring pressures from all
over the field so multiple and he would
get in your head as a quarterback
knowing okay i got to be prepared to
throw hop on all of these plays and then
i know i got revis over there one on one
so i mean it just shrinks your playbook
you know that on certain plays when that
that shutdown corner that you're
referring to is on that side of the
field you need to work that side of the
field
yeah i just can't imagine where you just
go
yeah and i mentioned of all the
positions if you're a great defensive
back chances are you're not going to be
on tv because you're never going in that
direction so we we would never you just
were told that jerrell reavis was great
you didn't really you didn't really see
it was there anybody else that you you
just when i got to stay away from his
side of the field
i mean namdi assemwa was a great great
corner he played a ton of man when he
was was
with the oakland raiders at the time he
would just lock you up and he was so
long and so physical that even if he
didn't cover you for the whole time he
was so great at the line of scrimmage he
would reach out and get his hands on you
and reroute the receiver so that by the
time you did get your eyes over there
you would see namdi with his hands
shoving your receiver almost out of
bounds or almost to the ground so you'd
have to get off that reed and move on
but that guy can be a game wrecker no
doubt and you're right i mean there's
not a lot of recognition there's not a
lot of interceptions that take you to
the pro bowl you don't get seven eight
nine ten interceptions in a year that
normally send a guy to the pro bowl that
guy normally gets three or four because
they only threw at him you know a dozen
or so times yeah but would you rather
worry about darrell rivas or ed reed
um
ed reed had a bigger impact on the game
because ed didn't just cover one
receiver ed
was told to play a certain coverage in
his helmet when the play came in and he
would read the offensive play and be in
a spot he was never supposed to be in
that could totally blow up a play or
intercept the ball so
ed was you know i loved playing against
ed and i hated playing against ed but he
was one of the best to do it for sure
but i'm wondering you talk about junior
seoul was like that troy palamalu was
like that these guys who sort of they
just go where they feel like they need
to go
and you're trying to call a play and
then you're trying to figure out okay i
got to account for these guys because
they're hall of famers how difficult is
to is that to do where somebody's
unpredictable
yeah you had to have three reads when
you played against the ed reed and troy
palamolo's of the world and most
defenses and defensive backs you had to
have two reads it was a pre-snap and a
post-snap read but then when you played
against one of those guys you had to
have a pre-snap read a post-snap lead so
once the ball was in your hands which
way they were going and then before you
threw it you had to eye them a third
time just to make sure they stayed in
that spot before you threw it to the
other spot so those were three reed
defenders for sure
it's hard enough to play the position
you got to factor in all of those things
yeah you got to be careful with those
ball hawks yeah hey great to talk to you
as always we appreciate your time carson
thank you buddy
thanks dan that's carson palmer his
weekly appearance during the nfl season
brought to you by our partner level
select cbd